So this guy, you may not know if you're a young baby.
It was right around my time in the eighties, George Brett was a,
was the man. He was a great baseball player on the Kansas city Royals.
So he became a coach or a, some kind of a manager or something for the, for the,
for the Royals. And there is, there is leaked video and audio of him.
Do you guys know about this? You do, right? Yeah, of course. Um,
where he is telling a younger player,
uh, well, you know what, let me just play it for you. This guy.
Let me just this guy, let me just start. Before I even played,
this is the most, this is more than hitting a,
a grand slam more than shagging. Fly balls,
more than eating sunflower seeds.
Waiting on the on-deck circle this
right here.
This three minutes is the most
baseball thing that has ever happened. Here we go.
It's unreal.
Back to the right gentleman, both hands right side, stretching.
George Brett stretching. Okay. It's weird to, by the way,
the manager is stretch. There's no reason for it.
You stand around and tell people what to do.
So he's stretching. So.
Now the
It's so crazy, by the way,
the manager dresses up in the uniform,
which is so sad. Hey,
that's sad. Imagine Pat Riley out there with a nix Jersey on,
is that what you know, he was Lakers. What was he? Nicks. Yeah. Got it. Right.
So of course it's Nick. You know why it's Nick's look at Pat Riley.
Couldn't be more New York. Hey. Hey,
so going on a little Terry, Pat Riley,
always saying that always on the Virginia last night. All right. All right.
All right. All right. All right.
Pardon? Pardon? He says, well, are you guys here stretch. Oh,
he farts. I didn't realize this.
That's what he says.
You hear that part.
Wow. Okay. So he farts stretching next to a player.
Pardon?
For, to not even IFR to do you know how, let me tell you something.
The ego you have to have on you to fart and then say
far too, is,
is the ego of someone who wears a robe.
It's just unbelievable. I,
my pants last night and then goes right into this story. Okay.
I shut my pants last night, dude. This is.
Fart. There's a one part of. My pants last night.
Okay. So now the younger players, like, okay, and he's just stretching.
And he says, I did.
I haven't had a great meal, just a great meal.
I had to go to the bathroom so bad in the car. I'm going to travel. Hurry up,
man. I got in my pants.
I wasn't. Audio is kind of weird, goes in and out,
but it gets better. Just listen. I'm good. Twice a year for that. Oh,
what was the last time? You. Your pants. Yeah. It's been awhile.
It's been a long time. I was in Vegas a couple years ago.
Just the honest to God. True story. I mean,
I just to want to stay at the Bellagio one over the Mirage for dinner and met
some friends of mine over there, went to Kokomo. So great.
Little steakhouse guy brings out some fresh crab legs. It's just came in.
I got to give them to you guys, bring some I'm eating them.
Then we'd go play gamble a little bit. I have a tee time early in the morning.
So I said, look, I got to get going. I'm walking back to the hotel.
I get three quarters away on the lobby. And all of a sudden I go, Oh.
And I'm standing here like this. I got my butt pinched. So I'm I'm.
I can't move. All of a sudden, you know,
felt right. I want just like this
poisoning from the crabs.
Take off my leather jacket around my waist.
I'm just standing there and it's just running down my leg.
I got jeans on black bucks. No socks,
walking. Every time I'm walking, coming out, it's water, straight water.
Then how sick I was sick. I was,
and then I'm standing outside my car and get on my cell phone. I called the guy.
I said, Larry, you won't believe this. I'm standing outside the Bellagio.
I can't move. I got everywhere. I all over myself. And Larry's about a 48 waist.
So he brings me over a pair of pants and some towels and some towels.
And so he, then he comes over and he meets me where I'm at,
tell him where I'm standing. Right. He finds the closest bathroom.
When you go up the escalator to go into the. I can't get in the elevator.
So, so he goes in, he finds the closest bathroom in a lobby of the hotel.
And then I get on the escalator and he kind of sounds like he dropped something.
So no one gets behind me, dude. You know this, I go in there.
He goes and gets the towel, rolls it over the who's talking to him.
He's walking away and he's following him. Wipe off, leave my shoes.
Look my shoes, my pants, everything right there.
The towels right there in the stall.
And I'm walking barefoot with my shirt and his pants that are 48 waist through
the lobby like this midnight, we're all walking away. Perfect.
Double tapered I've ever had in my life. Wait for it. Wait for it. True story.
Wait for it. Wait for it. Who's the pitchers in this game.
First of all, should know. You know,
it's his team who is, by the way, who's the pitchers in this game,
dude, nothing.
Yo you could hit a grand slam at with in the bottom of the ninth to win it
behind by three, with the bases loaded and the foot and account full.
And that is not more baseball than that. First of all,
he's wearing bucks with no socks, nothing more baseball than that dude.
And a leather jacket, dude. I can't believe how baseball this is.
This is inside baseball. They need to do a real sports on this brand.
Gumbo needs to be like George Brett, former golden glove winner,
a great manager for the Kansas city, Royals,
a hometown hero for his, for wherever he grew up.
Did you know? He,
his pants on the Bellagio and then they just need to deal with my dad.
I shipped my pants and I was running bucks.
He was the most baseball dressed person of all time.
He wore no socks and a leather jacket, dude, bro.
Imagine wearing no socks and a leather jacket. I, my pants last night.
That's who deserves to, their pants and the editor early tee time.
Nothing is more baseball than playing golf in the morning. Dude, this guy is,
this is unbelievable, dude.
This is more unbelievable than Darren Chris performance in the assassination of
Gianni Versace. This is dude and for,
my pants last night. True story. Who's the pitchers in this game, dude.
We got to.
Let me break it down. Cause we just played it back to the right gentleman.
Both hands right side.
So it's just it's before the game he's stretching. He shouldn't be.
He's just why'd you do the managers stretch and wear the uniform. Hey guy,
sad.
Well you all you guys, your truck. Isn't
part of the left side. My pants last night.
Wait, he's stretching in front of a guy.
The guy's face is in his and he farted and he says for the,
and that's so such a boss move dude.
And then the guy walks away. Nobody's like, they're like, okay, we gotta play.
Like you gotta watch a video. We'll show it on the video on our video podcast.
But like you, you gotta watch the video.
Cause the guys were all walking away and he's the manager and the players are
like, okay. Yeah. Cool. And I'm sorry, but the.
Stole off all my clothes.
She has 48 waste through the lobby like this midnight got up in the
morning, took the perfect double tapered I've ever had in my life.
True story. Who's the pitchers in this game,
dude.
Also, you don't have to say doubled tapered.
The first end is always tapered. Cause it's common out.
It's the second part that is sometimes not tapered, you know?
Perfect double taper. Wow. How baseball is it?
You got to watch this George Brett thing. God, it's so funny, man.
Who's the pitchers in the game tonight. Who's the pitchers in this game.
How old is George Brett?
That guy was the man golden globe winner golden glove winner. George Brett.
And let me do it thing. Yeah, go low.
I want to see the whole thing. Go, go to it. Know the, the text.
Just make it bigger. You know, make it bigger.
George Howard Breck born May 15th, 1953 are tired.
American baseball,
third basement and designed and designated hitter who played 21 years in major
league baseball for the Kansas city Royals
pick the most perfect double dipper.
To make it bigger, bro. I'm not a Eagle.
Um, Brett Brett's 3,154. I'm Brian Campbell.
Did you know George Brett's
3,154 career hits are the most by any third basement in major league history and
16th all time.
He is one of four players in the major league baseball association history to
accumulate 3000 hits.
But his biggest feat was his pants with no socks on the
Bellagio and wearing a 48 waist back to his hotel room.
So nobody knew. And when he woke up the next morning,
he took the most perfect double taper chip that you've ever seen.
And that's a true story. Who's the pitchers today.